so it's it's about time so 8 p.m. and I
will start at 8 p.m. Indian Standard
Time so I think we can start now so
hello everyone and thank you again for
joining this webinar on high throughput
biomedical data analysis this webinar is
organized by our team here at finder
Tech the webinar will cover several
topics from the upcoming biomedical data
science program that we will be
launching on September 16th
so at Pine biotech VR work constantly
working towards creating meaningful
curriculums in advanced topics in
bioinformatics and data science to
people with or without technical or
engineering backgrounds so in our omics
logic courses our focus is to share the
logic of the analysis and also to apply
these methods in competitive projects
and the projects that actually stands
out stands out in cutting edge
bioinformatics and biomedical research
so in this program we will focus you
know more on the data science techniques
that has to be embedded in our analysis
so that in future research you can move
into the right direction and get the
maximum insights from your data
so the goal of today's webinar is today
we will be introducing biomedical data
analysis techniques to you and
approaches that you can master and adopt
to help conduct better research of
course and learn about how data science
is changing you know the entire spectrum
of medical research
so from Diagnostics to treatment
selection and development of new
therapeutics and drugs it's very
important the role that data science is
playing these days because of the
enormous enormous volume of data that
has been generated on a regular basis
not on an everyday basis so during this
presentation we will walk you through
the smart syllabus of this program this
unique data science online program is
designed in a way so that everyone who
joins will have a complete data science
research experience working on
biomedical data sets we have four
aspects so we have four different
aspects of this program so we will start
with the understanding of biomedical
challenges and then we will move into
the exploratory data analysis and that
would be followed by ETA analysis and
visualization you can see here we are
trying to build better visualization for
the datasets that we are obtaining and
that we are processing and that we are
trying to you know separate or classify
so after the data visualization we will
look into the machine learning the
machine learning techniques how this
machine learning techniques are being
helpful in understanding the rightful
you know the meaning out of this big big
datasets so the course I mean as it has
been already talked about in the
previous webinar so the course will
start from a low introductory level so
we will start from the very basics and
then we will gradually together we will
advance towards the various techniques
used to understand this high dimensional
data so the biomedical data challenge
that we will be addressing and really
focusing on is the molecular data right
the multi omics data that we have
already
discussed in the previous webinar but
here again I mean the multi-omics data
we will be working towards the goal of
you know precision medicine that is
something that we can look forward to
and that has been in practice already in
many places using this enormous and you
know meaningful data that we have been
generating from even like from a patient
sample and and different you know
environmental factors there's so many
things so the biomedical challenge that
we are that will be addressed you in
this journey so you will see I mean we
will see how effectively we can utilize
these tools so one of such tool is our T
by n foot platform we will be using T
bands for platform which is a seamless
seamless and a very intuitive and I
guided platform we will be using that
for our analysis of high throughput data
followed by that we'll be using a lot of
you know ms excel and our studio where
we can you know take the output of the
program and learn how to visualize it
better and understand the meaning the
real meaning from those data sets so
here we are trying to you know walk you
through this journey of data science
where we will be talking about the
challenges will start from the
challenges and then we will move into
the exploratory data analysis we will
look into the data visualization and
then we will understand what does this
means so I mean we will be guided
throughout this journey this program is
organized by a scale team of a skilled
team of experts that have a diverse
perspective on challenges and methods
that we will be covering so we have dark
uma dean who is a director data
scientist at the university of montague
working he's working on a bio medical
and pharmaceutical clinical studies and
myself boyd Mazumdar i have a PhD in
computational biology and machine
learning so joining so can I ask you to
please mute yourself so that we can have
a you
no seamless lecture so yeah in this
course we will be sharing valuable
information about our experience working
with research labs and various
healthcare industry so before joining
the care Mia
I have worked on high-end bioinformatics
projects and problems well defined by
pharmaceutical companies working towards
drug discovery patient treatment or
personalized medicine so we will be
sharing all those insights that we have
gathered throughout you know our time
and we will use that experience to guide
you better during this journey so I mean
going into the details as I said we will
be discussing the syllabus here we will
be discussing what we will you know
going what we are going to you know
cover during this whole process so now
let's move on to the details of each
session so let's look what we are going
to cover day by day so after the
introductory introductory session on
16th of September so we start on this on
the first day 16th of September where
we'll be introducing everyone to the
platform and what all courses what all
material is available for you to take
and learn so after that session we will
be we will be talking we will be talking
about various data types in
high-throughput data analysis so last
time I mean last time in the previous
webinar we discussed about the raw data
like fast Q files as certified etcetera
but but the range of available resources
goes wider than that upon you know
directional search not only that you can
you know find raw data but you will also
see the lot of processed data you know
when you go to a go to repositories like
TCGA and the repositories like geo
datasets where we are finding lot of you
know large volumes of data deposited on
a regular basis you will also find a
expression so the the table expression
means that the data has been all they
are already processed from raw to now
you have a table of expression you will
find VCF files we see a file that
contains you know the mutational
variants you will directly find those
files and you can also find 16s right
Oh - OH - use so those things we will
get for metagenomics analysis so those
things are also available for you to you
know learn and explore the data that is
available out there so in this session
we will learn about the kind of data
that I just discussed in the session we
will also understand what can we do with
this data and how do we manage how do we
analyze this using the intuitive a I
guided T by info platform
so yes last time we showed you our
demonstration of how easily you know you
can access the platform the participants
of this program which will start on as I
said which will start on 16th of
September will have access to our
analytical P by info platform and the
educational platform has all the
resource plus the educational platform
which has all the resources associated
with the course and the material
available with this program will be
communicated to you so after that we
will learn about the various data types
associated with different analysis the
platform offers meaningful analysis and
methodological ologies for various multi
omics data analysis and interpretation
so last time we'll look into RNA seek
analysis in this session during the
course we will go deep into the
processing of NGS data we will look into
a cleaning of data we will look into the
processing of data using our semantic
pipelines so this is the one of the
biggest usps
so using the different sections of this
analytical platform so we have different
sections as last time you saw they were
like sections for NGS data analysis
their section for system biology
analysis their sections for machine
learning analysis data mining to be very
precise
so using this different sections the
platform which enables us to you know
easily very easily upload data and also
integrate the raw data following by the
you know processes like cleaning
processing the data using the logical
you know
schema of algorithms so after the
analysis what we are generating is a
table of expression from a row fast you
fight right so this is a specialized
bioinformatics pipeline as you as you as
it is shown here they are they are
connected to you know a logical scheme
of analysis and the same analysis like
the this pipeline is as you can see here
if you what is the advantage of learning
about the pipelines which are hosted in
T bar and for platform there is a
question like this that comes up so the
answer to it is like the analysis the
same analysis could be implemented not
only here but outside the platform as
well so what you want to learn what what
would make it happen so you have to
follow the same logic right once you
understand the logic of how to connect
and how to you know why to connect these
different steps and if you understand
that so you can translate that into you
know any kind of environment and that is
one of the benefits of this program so
yeah if I have to summarize here we will
start with the introduction and then we
will look into the big data coming from
these high throughput techniques for
example here we will we will extract the
you know table of expression as I said
and then we will move into the
statistical analysis so for the next
section I would like to invite our kuma
Dean to talk about the statistical
properties of the data so I'll just stop
sharing and I will let Darko to share
his screen and give you the insights
you
Thank You Mohit so as Mohit said
sometimes we will deal with huge amounts
of data now this data will come in a
variety of formats so for example our
data could come in a table format
we will want to summarize our data for
example find central points of the data
and explain the variability inside it
from the descriptive statistics we will
get an output that contains numerical
values like means or medians or for
example standard deviations
is we are showing you an example of
visualizing the medians on the left side
of the image take a look at the medians
and take a look at how they relate to
the whole data
we'll deal with many other aspects of
descriptive statistics analysis for
example here you can see q1 q3
interquartile range and many other
statistics we will cover them in detail
during the program on the other hand
data could come on a scales of different
magnitude so these magnitudes should be
aligned in order for us to create a more
comparable data we will use a method
called quantile normalization which can
be accessed on the T by 4 platform and
we'll be aligning these medians from
different scales different file formats
different data formats and once we align
them they will be more comparable later
in the course we'll be dealing with more
data visualization tools for exploratory
analysis we'll be using
box plots histograms scatter plots to
analyze correlations and associations
between the variables and analyze the
distribution of the data this exempt on
the left you can see two scatter plots
explaining correlations between two
variables or to two parts of the data
for example these could be two genes and
we can see the red line showing a trend
of correlation between them now we can
use these trend lines to analyze the
nature of the Association but take a
look at the upper scatter plot our data
is agglomerating on the lower left part
of the chart and it's very hard to
visualize the whole thing but after
normalizing the data which is in this
case non-normalized typically RNA seek
data will be like this but we could use
you
we can also create a predictive model
out of this so we could predict values
of Y based on values of X the whole
point is to find a predictive model that
is most accurate that has least errors
in it so we'll be dealing with least
error prediction models on the other
hand we don't have to analyze two
variables we could include more
variables in the analysis and we could
combine the regression with factor
analysis to identify for example genes
that could be important factors for a
certain disease now when dealing with
big data very often we will have a huge
amount of variables huge amount of data
for example huge amounts of samples and
huge amounts of genes in our data sets
we'll be dealing with datasets that
contains several thousand genes so we
will want to choose the genes or parts
of the data that will be most relevant
to our research for example a large
number of these genes are irrelevant for
breast cancer research
let's say we have several types of
breast cancer samples right now large
part of the genes will be normally
expressed in them just a portion of the
data will be important for us to make a
distinction between these breast cancer
subtypes use a method called PCA or
principal component analysis to extract
parts of the data that are most relevant
to our research PC it does is it selects
part of the data let's say from a huge
data set that hits the most variants in
it why is this done because the error
that has more variance separates
subgroups much better
so principal component analysis will
create
species or principal components in a
certain order
for example pc-1 pc2 pc3 ATC and the
first pcs will be the PCs that explain
most of the variants that are best used
to separate our data in this case we
have an example of breast cancer
subtypes for example luminal subtype
which is marked as blue here is
separated on the PCA from the rest of
the breast cancer subtypes by PC one or
the principal component that has most of
the variants a principal component
analysis can be improved even more using
software like R so we can combine T by
if a platform to conduct initial PCA
analysis and then combine this with tool
like our or our studio to improve our
PCA you can see on the right PCA that we
actually separated for breast cancer
subtypes and we were able to customize
the plots to draw some borders we can
review the overlaps between these
subtypes and calculate their distances
we'll talk about this more in detail
during the program now I hit you on the
clustering part
Thank You doc oh I mean yes I mean I you
guys learned that unsupervised method is
PCA is one of the way to look into the
data visualize it so it's an
unsupervised method which means that the
data you are looking at is not labeled
right so if you guys can see my screen
can you guys see my screen
yes because
thank you no you can't
I think it's just going to load in a way
I fancy it now yeah thank you so yeah
Thank You doc oh I mean so after
performing the PCA which helped us to
visualize the data so we are going into
a flow here first we first we did what
we did is we extracted data from the
high-throughput
analysis from raw data we came to
expression table and that expression
table is nothing but something which is
made of you know columns and rows so we
have matrix of data which which contains
multiple you know multiple information
about different samples and different
genes so there are thousands of samples
there could be thousands of genes right
so what PCA did was PC helped us to
visualize that data and that high
dimensional data so okay and then you
saw that we can classify them into
different groups using you know our
specialized customizations that are
available within the probe within the
platform and also we used our specially
to you know for a better visualization
and also that that would be covered in
much detail in much detail in in the
course so we have a specialized course
for our that helps people and that helps
our participants you know to not only
see the classification but also you know
derived meaningful biological
interpretation from that data so which
is included in this course of course so
we discussed about the PCA now what we
will try which is like another very
popular unsupervised method is
clustering right so during this program
we will use hands-on example with
clustering algorithms like I think many
of you have heard about the k-means
clustering algorithm we will covered we
will cover k-means we will do
hierarchical clustering we will do DB
scan which is mostly density based you
know clustering and we will combine them
with heat
Maps to improve the visualization of the
analysis as I said and we will find
patterns in the signatures of those
separate clusters so in the session when
during this session we will learn about
various clustering methods algorithms
that it's you know distances and
boundaries to separate data so yeah one
of the examples like we will next we
will go into one of the examples that
are present in you know that we did in
our one of our breast cancer sample data
set that we have been talking about so
this is just a overview of the
supervised analysis methods that are
available in the platform so we have
different methods and those methods have
different parameters so hierarchical
clustering orders you know the rows and
the columns based on similarity so it's
this makes it easy to see you know
correlation out of the results from
hierarchical clustering you would be
able to see better correlations so
during the clustering or session we will
use various examples like in this case
what you can see here is a section where
you can see where you can see you can
define parameters like you know linkage
distance and the number of clusters that
you expect to you know get from this
data transposition
to understand you know transpose between
the rows in the column so you will have
different parameters that will be taught
and we will not make you understand why
this lineage method is you know better
for a certain data set why this distance
is taken into consideration when we look
into you know different data sets so
it's mostly about the application not
just the methodology you will go into
the algorithm in detail we will talk
about the application of that algorithm
in a real data set so I mean what we are
trying to do here I mean what is
important in you know hierarchical
clustering here is that the output of
the hierarchical clustering gives us the
separation right so
kisses the seperation between different
groups present in our unlabeled data set
the important question however is when
we are doing hierarchical clustering how
do we determine in the similarity of the
simple right how do we determine which
samples are similar to each other or or
in other words how do we determine the
distance between the data points you
know which are there and then link them
to different clusters that are present
so we are looking what we are looking at
is we are looking at the relationship
between the samples based on their gene
expression and you know hierarchical
clustering is based on a bottoms-up
approach so bottom-up approach so we
have classified the samples into
separate groups using in the next step
so you can see here like in the
dendogram here which is so shown excuse
me so yeah I think yeah I got the mouse
cursor so the dendogram if you can see
here
I mean it divides the classes if I draw
a line here it will divide up divide the
clusters into 4 classes 1 here 2 here 3
here 4 here so you can see we can divide
this data into four distinct classes
right so using in the next step I mean
once we have you know data once we have
classified samples into different groups
what could be the next step so using the
next step would be to use the supervised
machine learning methodologies so we
have seen so far that we can possibly
you know group unknown unlabeled data
into you know different clusters so what
could be the next step the next step
would be to separate these groups into
different classes and then make a
training and test data set to see how
does this unsupervised learning
algorithms that would mean we would see
how this unsupervised learning
algorithms will work on the lab labelled
data and how they perform you know what
we are trying to do here is to classify
or find important genes that can you
know classify the breast cancer subtypes
into different categories
so that's a purpose that's a biological
question that we are asking here and you
we are using different algorithms which
are giving us different outputs which
gives us different insights that why
this gene is important you know for you
know discriminating between maybe
basal-like or Claudian low or normal
life or you know different cancer
subtypes so that's the purpose and
that's what we are going to learn in
this course so I mean we talked about
unsupervised we talked about PCA we
talked about hierarchical clustering and
different clustering methods now as we
as you saw like here you saw that we
have been able to divide you know
different groups you saw here in PCA we
have divided them into different groups
so we have now defined clusters so the
clusters are well separated so that we
can Nick them into you know into a
training and test dataset so next is
something called the supervised machine
learning method now we have a training
and a test data set to evaluate the
performance of our classifier so what
why we are using you know so many
different machine learning algorithms so
many machine learning algorithms you saw
like in one session there are multiple
machine learning methods available in
the platform so why we are using those
machine learning methods different
machine learning methods on different
data sets different machine learning
methods on a single data set what
insights does these different methods
give us so I will come to that in this
webinar but we will discuss it more and
more in our in the program itself so I
mean we saw how these trees are you know
classifying your you know data so
basically if we have to separate
everything into you know series of rules
so a decision tree is what a decision
tree asks that question yes or no it
starts with a random initialization so
we will look at an example I mean then I
think we will be able to understand
better we look into an example of breast
cancer cell lines and maybe then we will
be able to understand how actually
decision tree works so
we are looking at a decision tree of 15
genes so 15 genes plus those 15 genes
have you know we are looking at the
after expression of those 15 genes from
you know different samples so we have
different number of samples available so
we have a lot of basal sample available
a lot of claudin low available a lot of
luminal available and lot of normal like
samples are available so based on that
data set we are trying to classify them
into something called this so let me
explain qu what what we are actually
looking at so we when we are talking
about differentially expressed genes
typically we refer to you know some sort
of profile that looks like this this is
a gene okay so what we are looking at is
is here you can see a group of samples
where the expression of the gene is you
know up regulated here you see this gene
is up regulated in a group of sample so
I think the the phones are very small
but the thing that I'm trying to tell
you here is like these samples have been
you know put into one specific you know
they have a high expression it's quite
visible here this gene which is the
output of the decision tree gives us you
know gives us a separation based on
single gene that okay if we choose this
gene this gene can you know help us
separate this group into different sets
so in this example there are two genes
so there is one gene here there is one
gene here so two genes out of 15 that
are helping us classify these cell types
you know there's the subtypes into three
you know three groups so gene six two
nine nine here and gene nine triple
eight here in combination can
distinguish whether a sample belongs to
cell type basal luminal and Claudine
load so how did we manage to understand
this how did we reach here those are the
things that we will be covering in the
you know in the in the program that how
we interpret a decision tree how that
one
that algorithm is be is being able to
come to a decision where it can you know
use one gene or two gene to classify two
big data sets that is something that is
that is decision tree right but there
are many problems with the decision tree
as I said there are several problems one
of which is that that algorithm works
with random initialization so from your
data set it will just start randomly
from anywhere that's one problem the
first tree will start from someplace and
we will try to find the optimal genes
that accept that are separating the data
sets into you know whatever classes that
you saw so the cause the the issue is in
with the decision tree is the accuracy
the accuracy and the stability so
because you are doing a random
initialization and you have generated
one tree and you know this is not highly
accurate practice so we have found a
problem to this we have found a problem
of you know resolving this decision tree
and that that solution is nothing else
but a very another very popular method I
think which is random forest right so
random forest what is happening in
random forest and why random forest of
decision trees so we are running
actually multiple decision trees at a
single time that is called random forest
so when in random forest instead of
running one decision tree we are running
may it many many times
like right we have one instances so the
whole idea is to actually develop an
algorithm that does actually run the
decision tree many many times in order
to focus on the stability and the
accuracy of the result which was missing
in the decision tree so you see right
here we have an instance okay we started
from an instance and there are multiple
random initialization so we are
generating many many trees and then we
see some predictions you know happening
here some predictions happening here so
this optimal path which which led to
this this result could happen again so
it's not I mean fixed that the
initialization if had already happened
with one in two
it will not happen with the same integer
again so it can happen again and again
so what what is the result I mean I mean
after you're doing it many many times
you might you might ask that how do you
conclude that what is the right optimal
path or the right optimal genes because
we are getting so many you know so many
instances so what actually happens in
random forests is it's very interesting
I mean it's like we do voting so if this
result is coming many times if this
result is coming many times if this
result is coming many times over and
over then the probability of that result
to be correct is high right so that's
how random forest works we will go into
much more detail where we will talk
about you know the algorithms the
booting and bootstrapping all those
things we will cover and we'll make you
understand how it is you know affecting
the analysis of the data that we are
doing how you know running different
this is a computationally expensive
process because you're running so many
different trees at the same time so we
will discuss all those things in details
but this is an overview how we are going
to deal with this data and how you know
with you know relevant examples we will
be talking about this in detail so yeah
so another example like as you said we
saw the trees right we saw how trees and
how they work we saw the tree based
classification now we will move into a
line based or the data transformation
method which is the LDA this is also
again a very popular method
discriminant analysis and classification
so what we are here trying to do is like
you know the the tool classification so
we are dividing you know the training
data set and the test data set and then
we are looking at performance how these
separations are actually working using
these different techniques so one thing
I talked about previously that we are
using different you know algorithms we
are using different algorithms on a
single data set how does that you know
benefit us so here you saw I mean here
in decision tree you got what two genes
you got two genes right here and here to
classify here actually when you see the
result of decision tree you godard you
get a bunch of genes not one gene like
maybe fifteen gee maybe seven gene maybe
age
that that you know is helping you to
classify or you know to segregate into
different trusses or you know to tell
that this is the gene that belongs to
this class something like that so here
you are getting a signature you are you
getting a gene signature because you're
not getting one too but you're getting
many so you understood why we are using
different methods because different
methods are not only you know giving us
different results but it's also giving
us different insights from this data so
one data set which is that big I have so
much information so different algorithms
work in a different way to extract those
information which is equally an
important equally important for us for
you know to conduct a good quality
research even to you know many of you
might work in industry where the demand
is to you know reach to a conclusion
which is you know more effective so the
data driven approaches the hypothesis
before this there was a hypothesis
driven approaches now it's more data
driven approaches so what is the benefit
of data driven approach is that we are
coming to you know a highly accurate
answer which helps us to reduce the
bench work or which is helping us to
reduce the amount of you know the hard
work the amount of money that goes into
you know bench that amount of money that
goes into doing experiments but lab
experiments so if we can have a you know
a very specific answer we can just you
know design an experiment for that and
that would help us not only to reduce
the amount of you know expenditure but
the biggest advantage one of the biggest
advantage is the time so in pharma you
know as we all have heard to reach out
you know not to make a drug which is
very effective it takes like a huge
amount of you know time as a 15 year or
a long you know time scale and also it
has you know lot of you know problems in
terms of you know coming to a definitive
result so that those are the measure
those are the things that can be
overcome while you use multiple methods
like you know ldea
decision tree and look into your data
very closely and then come to an you
know there and then come to a solution
so yeah we were talking about decision
discrimination analysis to discriminant
analysis this the idea is here the idea
here is to you know define or you know
discriminate between different types of
samples so we are removing so those
features which are not important we are
removing in a nitrated process and we
are moving forward like this so I mean
let's go into little bit more detail
into LD a so in some in some sense LD a
or linear discriminant analysis which
could be which could be said as you know
supervised alternative of PCs so PCA is
a PCA is unsupervised method but LD a is
you know something you can compare it
with LD a and how and why because
instead of finding the best principal
component that separates all the samples
based on variance here we will find some
line that accurately separate our
classes and there are many different
variations of LDL okay so here you can
see linear LD a you can see quadratic LD
a you can see diagonal LD a so will
these all are based on different
assumptions about the distribution of
the data we will go into much detail in
our class put LD a process how it how we
are using different methods and what are
the different data diamonds that we are
talking about LD a we are doing it for
one instance and I tried a version of da
just like we had a curative version of
decision tree is called their pie school
it is useful filters for the same sets
as the random forest is useful you know
in comparison to decision tree if we
will still see does the operation you
know different here we will get a best
different best separation in a trend
principle or a different album the
algorithm that Lda uses is called greedy
algorithm so who
kill but go to city as a separation
methods like Lda
and SVM or something which helps us to
understand the classification in a
better manner because we are training
that it is set and then we are asking
the classifier - you know classifying
new data sets which are which we have no
clue about so once you have developed
this protocol once you have developed a
model it's it's fairly easy in the next
step - you know predict for the new
classes but but the the the challenge
remains in you know developing a good
model that is something that we want to
discuss in this entire program so that
the the the output of the analysis that
you are getting many people use machine
learning nowadays because it's very
popular what they don't understand is
that how these different techniques deal
data differently so that is very
important I think to move forward so the
result of stepwise Lda is going to be
that so we can get a good separation we
can understand based on which genes you
know we selected and features and then
we can do downstream analysis of those
genes and understand how the biology of
it how the interpretation of these genes
correlate with our findings so another
method which I said is SVM which is
another very popular method so I'm not
going into much detail so SVM is a very
effective algorithm which what it does
it's it takes the input space and it
converts it into a new type of space so
where it is you know easy to separate
your samples right so you can see here
the samples are inside samples inside
are surrounded so this is class one and
the sample outside is class two so this
is a difficult separation you know so
what we need to do is maybe transform
this space so how do we transform this
space this transport although the the
trick here is kernel SVM uses different
type of kernels to transform this space
so that it could improve the
classification your a radial basis for
learn kernels their linear corners a
different type of kernels that
and - easy - you know that helps us easy
to transform and separate the spaces
into different categories so it's very
fascinating I mean once you start you
know aptly applying this data and see
different results you would understand
how these methods actually work in in
tandem or how these methods are working
you know in in a collaboration for a
dataset so I mean once you learn in this
in this phase we have initially learned
about the data now we have learned about
the techniques now in the next phase we
will move into the case studies where we
will see the application of both in in
one place so I will just give the stage
to Darko to tell a more you tell more
about the application of these
techniques and the case studies that we
will be covering used in our you know in
our upcoming program thank you all to
you doc oh please stop the sharing okay
so as you saw we will be dealing with a
variety of aspects from data science
will be dealing with huge data sets
mainstream statistics machine learning
algorithms and many other things but you
don't need to have previous knowledge or
experience regarding these matters
because we will be starting from the
very basics things then we will go
through all the is aspects we spoke
about for example we will teach you some
principles in how to choose which button
to use for which data for example we
here unlabeled data we have not
predefined the groups and we will use on
to bar learning methods like PCA or H
cluster define groups and now we will
use random forests and qda or
discriminant analysis to classify the
data Forest will apply all these
on hands-on exemplar projects so on
October 21 we will start with projects
from oncology areas now in these
projects we will have various types of
data we will have data that are just
images or visual data types as you can
see here we have an x-ray which is
actually a mammogram showing a tumor on
the picture so they're used by doctors
to identify early signs of cancers using
x-ray him there's many other visual data
types like biopsies histologies to
analyze the visual aspect of the
clinical data like data will complement
this analysis so for example we have
biomarkers for some cancers but it's
just one biomarker it's just one program
what if there are many other processes
that occur in the development of this
cancer that we are not dealing with
right so we want to analyze multiple
types of data for example gene
expression patterns and other molecular
types of data like the ones we see on
the right we can see a heat map here
representing gene expressions Green is
the higher expression and the red is
lower expression so we can see that
there are more cancer subtypes here each
one of them has its own pattern of gene
expression oh when we go to the project
itself modeling precision treatment of
breast cancer we will be dealing not
just with molecular profiling and
clinical data types but also responses
from 138 therapies so these combined and
with the use of machine learning methods
we mentioned a trade model can
created that would be able to predict
therapy response of each patient based
on all these types of data so in the end
a treatment response prediction model is
created for 22 Terra piece and each new
patient that is analyzed based on these
molecular profiling 's and breast cancer
clinical data types each treatment
response could be predicted 24th we will
start exemplar projects in microbiology
area so we will analyze bacillus
tuberculosis and drug resistance that is
developed to antibiotics
but through omics data and using these
data science methods on the other hand
we will here have a project that is
related to Ebola or a bola outbreaks in
West Africa this is an outbreak that
occurred between 2013 and 2016 in
various parts of West Africa like Sara
Leone Liberia and many other so the
outbreak was very infective you know so
the virus itself become became more
infective because some changes occurred
in the glycoproteins on the surface of
the virus how the virus infects human
cells it infects them by these
glycoproteins so human dendritic cells
interact with the glycoproteins on the
virus and that's how the infection
occurs now a single change in these
glycoproteins could make the virus more
infective and spread much faster like
the like the situation we have at hand
so we will have an
per project with datasets from different
parts originating from different parts
of Africa containing multiple omics
types and we will use machine learning
algorithms and data science to analyst
will create pipelines on the T by
InfoPath firm we will map the
transcriptions we will use variant
calling differential variant calling and
we'll cover this in detail during the
program and in the end we will identify
these changes or mutations that cause
the papyrus to become so in fact on the
other hand we will have projects from
various series they are not limited just
to oncology or microbiology we will be
analyzing exemplar projects from asthma
studies for example or studies related
to and the chronology to diabetes so
that is the key concept of this program
we'll teach you how to analyze the data
how to access the data we'll teach you
how to perform data science and machine
learning but we will apply these to a
large number of exemplar projects so
this is not just some online course this
is a hands-on practically oriented
program and we will be there with you
from the beginning to the end and
implementation of this questions
regarding the program we will teach you
how
the data in a very easy way from sources
like NCBI or fibrils or EMBL entrez
uniprot and many others
we'll teach you how to interpret a plan
of analysis when you access the data so
this will be a three month more than
three months in duration so in the first
two months we will be teaching you how
to apply these methods then after
October 31st you will start with your
own data process you will select your
own datasets and you will have
approximately more than a month to be
guided by us with all arising issues in
applying the methods we taught you
before so right now I will give some
more insights into the program thank you
thank you so much Norco and that was an
excellent guidance that you gave us oh
yeah I mean as as you saw I mean we will
be covering at the theoretical part and
we will be talking about the lots of
hands-on practice during the whole
process and we will finish the details
and we'll be having one-on-one talk with
you we will be having group talks to you
know discuss more about the details of
these pro you know this projects that
we'll be doing next and after the
projects we will be talking about you
know the outcome of the project so there
it's it's our journey I think which will
be a very fascinating journey together
we will where we will collaborate and
learn together on different domains so
we will start this on September the 16th
this month only we only have six days to
go for this program and as you see we
are all very excited to you know start
this program with a group of enthusiasts
who wants to learn and not only learn
but also apply these methods into real
life problems so
what is this project or this whole you
know program is bringing as we keep on
saying that we will go through the
methods will not just go through the
methods and learn and understand about
the details of each of these methods we
will also apply these methods to
clinical research and pharmaceutical
projects then we will design and prepare
you will design and prepare and plan
your own analysis which could be
impactful so built based on these
projects and analysis examples what you
will do is that you will learn how to
handle important project an important
biomedical research that could
eventually lead to you know something
translational like a publication or like
a grant or you know different things
when you're working in a company you're
looking at a problem and in the end you
will obtain a certificate an
international certificate which could be
of high value where you will be getting
the knowledge which which will be
transmitted you know you transfer into
all these time and will be you know
finishing this course at this point of
time so it tells it does gives a lot of
you know value so we will come we will
start from 16th of September and we will
go till end of October during this
journey wave you will be you know
talking about as as you saw if you will
be talking about the challenge first and
then we will look into the data and how
the challenge is and we have to
understand that why this is a challenge
first of all why this is such an issue
and what this platform brings you you
know to you know to simplify things and
dive into the actual problem rather than
focusing on myths rather than focusing
on the understanding the output of those
methods we will dive into something
really translational that would help us
to do something you know which is the
need of the art so we will cover all
these during our sessions and it will be
an interactive it will be always like
this will be an interactive session
where we'll be you know connected blue
using do flat forms that we have we have
various platforms on social media we
have whatsapp groups we have been
reaching out to all of our students for
different different type of queries that
they have so we are interactive and it
will be a collaborative effort between
you and the Pine biotech team and us
it's a journey that looking forward to
so the end of the I think have any
questions for us you mean during this
presentation so please go ahead
unmute cell alright and that's at and
asked asked a question that how I mean
if you have any questions regarding to
the webinar and also the program I know
yeah hello you yeah you can you know
please go ahead
hello yeah one she please go ahead one
she yes yes yeah thank you
I just we use our pseudo here right yeah
so we need to have so if I can answer
that question
so our studio is as we will be using our
studio for better visualization so we
get the data from the cloud-based our
server and then we will look into manual
installation of those programs in your
computer so we'll be guiding you how to
do that as well you'll be guiding you
which libraries we will be using so yeah
so there will be no issues you know -
it's a downstream analysis so that can
be you know different users have
different you know different
publications different user have
different you know need so it's
something
which is personalized but we'll be
guiding you through the whole process
yeah we will be guiding you from the
basic things like how to download the
art studio and then how to use the
platform or the excel or how to
customize plots in the art studio so
we'll be covering all those topics from
the very beginning and then going to
more advanced things Thanks yeah hi like
for some time I've been facing this and
I haven't have a question like the
actual data in to the to get data into
the platform and work is being little
difficult for me like I have I probably
have an extension to this same question
that one see are just not so possible
actually to download these to have these
the tools working on Mac system and work
on it or do you think that this platform
would help me for complete analysis of
the time I want to do so we'll be
combining the platform with other tools
right so where it's easier to use the
platform you will use the platform but
then you can combine these with tools
like Excel our studio and many other
tools to overcome these obstacles right
so you will do the data processing very
quickly on the platform but then you can
customize it more in other tools yeah
and the tools have been tested in
different platforms Sunita so Macintosh
or Linux and Windows we have tested in
all those platforms so they if they all
of those software's work well in all
those platforms so you're going to walk
us through how to download those in our
own systems yeah yeah definitely and so
if if I need an access to greater chunk
of data in to like to download and
like that processing is faster on the
platform right so if I want to get the
access to greater chunk of data that I
want to download so that's also possible
right absolutely we will teach you will
teach you to how to access the data in
an efficient way
what are the repositories that you could
use to download the data or access it in
other URL formats to create a more
efficient data access so we will card
that program yes I didn't see any it
seems like it is a separate course again
you have to register for is it that data
visualization is included in the program
you have seen that we will use various
data visualization tools like histograms
I don't know we visualize the
regressions will visualize a clustering
many other types of machine learning and
data visualization will also customize
these visualization are so that there
are interpretable more intuitive right
so yes we will cover those topics in the
program in detail oh thank you
any more questions
okay I will I will repeat this for Arnab
because he missed the part of the
session so we will have a large amount
of example projects so we will teach you
how to use data science but we will also
have example projects in areas of
oncology microbiology but also many
other areas like we will be analyzing
data types asthma and machine learning
combined we will use data science on
diabetes and many others so we will have
example projects in our program one more
question from Sunita ok so now we are
having only this program right that is
starting on September 16th yes right yes
so I just want to make sure I'm not
missing upon anything because I miss
most of them because I have my classes
and I have a lab also to work in where I
go I miss most of the I want to be yeah
sure I mean we will record every session
and we will send it out to every
participant and then we will have yeah
and I'm also concerned about having
these recordings for a longer time
because they're really really yeah we
can send you the videos as well yeah
like if I can have it for myself is that
possible that I have it for myself for
ever yeah yeah sure I mean that's what I
said just take care that's a great thing
thank you so much no problem ok any more
questions
I don't think we have more questions but
I mean yeah we I mean we are looking
forward for you guys to join us for this
journey together right Darko yes thank
you so much and we're looking forward
I'm going as a beautician of the poor's
generation of the class can you repeat
the question
Muniz are asking about the duration of
okay so the derails of the class will be
one hour per class and we will have two
classes per week so we will notify the
the ones that join the program in
advance of each date for the class but
generally that's it we'll have two
classes per week and we'll cover a
three-month program with two months of
teaching and the third month will be
reserved for you to start your own
project and we will be there to help you
and guide you with all the issues that
arise okay
any more questions thank you so much
Katya now days of the week will vary we
will you hear the dates in the webinar
but I will repeat them we will hear
dates like Monday and Thursday sometimes
they will be Monday and Wednesday but
that's it those are generally the dates
and any more questions
okay thank you thank you everyone for
joining us here today and we'll be
looking forward you looking forward for
your presence on 16th of September as
well thank you brother man King thank
you okay okay thank you everyone thank
you protein thank you Mohit for a
fantastic lecture thank you everyone for
attending the webinar and we look
forward seeing you in the program Thank
You doc oh thank you Maureen thank you
all thank you for a great webinar thank
you yeah